you should be able to say to your
partner can I have your phone I have to
check something and they should be like
yeah of course you should have each
other's codes there should be so much
trust that no one's going to Snoop so
much trust that like there's nothing
that you're hiding that's the level of
trust that is really necessary in a
relationship what happens when trust has
been broken
depends how it's been broken was it
broken because an affair was it broken
because your partner said that they
wanted to do this for a living and they
decided to Pivot and do something else
for a living if it's an affair Affairs
can be extremely complicated and
oftentimes what you'll find is that it's
not a 50 50 split of who's responsible
but even the person who was cheated on
if they want to work on the relationship
they will see that they played a role in
whatever was not working in the
relationship it does not condone the
behavior